next thing for any video is the starting
has to be awesome you want to hook
people right away so step one is just in
terms of The Branding does this person
look like somebody who I want to learn
from it doesn't have to be back to Titan
twin content you don't have to look like
you're Oprah Winfrey but does it look
like you know what I've been through and
can you solve my problem so you know
Alex in here doing his salsa dancing
this should be a salsa dance at the top
right it shouldn't just be Alex's face
it should be people's salsa dancing if
Zane's doing one around confidence it
should feel like I'm gonna get more
confidence just by looking at the banner
and the Avatar so that's step one like
branding are you the person that I think
will help me solve my problem step two
is then with your click-through rate
having thumbnails and titles that will
get people to want to click on the video
and then step three is keeping people in
the video